nous on a notre temps avec et ça nous
regarde et on a vous a préparé un petit
truc sur danse avec les stars
ça rejoint un petit peu ce que dit
gilles verdez est ce que dit adorer mon
regard semir c'est la panique chez tf1
plus aucune star ne veut faire le
casting de danse à des crises part alors
en exclusivité voici le prochain casting
de danse avec quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un connait des stars
il connaît un gars qui connaît un autre
gars qui aurait fait un selphy avec kev
adams et ces gens-là redisent
beau frère a croisé thierry beccaro aux
urinoirs de la gare saint charles de
marseille
c'est marina moulineaux
il était à l'école au cp avec la fille
s'est remariée avec un chauffeur gruber
qui a transporté le frère du cousin d'un
sosie de philippe risoli ses pattes
bouchard il a le 06 du prince albert de
monaco le mail laeticia hallyday il faut
le même louis smith sur twitter et
pourtant aucune de ses stars ne le
connaît c'est bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]